اه
النجا تويتر من القرارات المتسرعات قد
ياخذ خطي يتبوا مكان جدا كويس في مناصات
التواصل اجتماعيه كل منصات التواصل
اجتماعيه خلال سنوات الماضيه نمت نمو جدا
عالي انستقرام انما نمو عالي جدا فيسبوك
لما نمو عالي جدا تيك توك طلع بعد تويتر
وانما نمو عالي جدا لكن تويتر اعداد
المستخدمين في كانت بسيطه جدا لذلك
القنوات هذه والتسريعات هذه في فرصه جدا
كبيره وذهبيه لتويتر انه ينمو ويصل الى
اعداد كبير المستخدمين وياخذ مكان اخر لو
في حاله لا سمح الله صارت تعطل في خدمه
انتهاء خدمه معينه لم نشاط التواصل
اجتماعيه ترى ليست مستمره في من الصلاه
التواصل اجتماعيه انتهت فيه من اصوات
اجتماعيه توقفت كانت في شبكات اجتماعيه
موجوده وانتهت حاليا هي ما هي موجوده في
حياتنا كانت موجوده فيها 9,000 10 2011
فلذلك تويتر اذا واصل النمو بشكل كويس
وغير من طريقه عمله
ده فرصه جدا ذهبيه ان يقدم خدمات كثيره
ومستخدمين وينمو نمو جدا كبيره
لان استكمال الاعلانات اعتقد انخفضه
نمو في اعداد المستخدمين ووصول اعداد
المستخدمين جدا كبير يعني في اعلانات اكثر
من قبل الشركه عن الشركات تعتمد عليهم شكل
كبير لانه تويتر يعتبر منصه جدا جدا همم
لشركات المختلفه وقال انه ما راح يعتمد
بشكل كبير على الاعلانات يعني صحيح في
تحقيق ارباح او نمو همم يعني المنصه
فبالتالي على اي اساس ممكن يعتمد وش
الخيارات البديله الخيارات البديله دفع
المستخدمي للاموال للتوثيق او الحصول
ثمانيه دولار لان التوثيق او الخدمات
الاضافيه اللي ممكن يحصل عليها منصه همم
مثلا فيديو اعلى فيديو اطول للناس قد
تساهم في توفير مدخول وللمعلويه تركيه
تواصل اجتماعيه تعاني من قوانين الخصوصيه
الجديده
اللي ساهمت في تقليد دقه الاعلانات بشكل
بسيط وهذا ادى ان صار في تخوف عندهم سناب
شات قاعد تخسر بسبب همم
قوانين خصوصيه جديده وللمعلميه ترا سناب
شات خلال فتره خلال سنوات الماضيه ربع
واحد حققت فيك ارباح الربع الثاني ترى
محققت فيها ارباح وفيسبوك حقق ارباح كويسه
لكن عند انهيار حاليا